he's now the highest paid defensive
player in the nfl after signing a
five-year contract extension worth 135
million dollars
chargers defensive end joe ibosa joining
us on the program
how did you celebrate the new contract
it was pretty pretty uneventful just uh
pretty much got to bed early and got
ready for the next day at camp
don't you feel like you should do
something
oh no yeah this week this past weekend
we had a great dinner
a little champagne and uh but that's
about it it's it's not the best time to
be
be celebrating right now going into camp
is it assumed that you'll pick up the
check
uh no at least this dinner it was uh
i guess it was probably the last split
we're gonna do in a long time
but but if you and your brother go out
who's picking up the check uh
i'll probably make him do it every once
in a while
no because i know what's coming to him
in the future so
we'll we'll go back and forth how's this
off season been
it's been long you know um kind of weird
and
with all the uncertainty it's a little
nerve-wracking
not knowing whether you're gonna get a
season or not but
i've just been staying focused staying
on my training and uh
just felt like an extended off season
with the no with no otas to break it up
but uh it's been good
do you work out by yourself no nick
trains with me
oh okay do you haze him at all do you
beat him up like
big brother does to a little brother
well those days are long ago
when was the last time you beat him up
when's the last time
oh gosh uh a lot a while ago
um once that the size difference slimmed
down a bit it was
no more bullying going on so it's not
like like the gronkowskis it feels like
those guys are always
you know hitting each other in the groin
and beating each other up wrestling and
stuff like that
yeah i think things would get a little
too serious at this point
um how many teammates do you stay in
touch with here during the offseason
um a decent amount uh
just try to check in on how they're
doing throw some text out there i mean
um they're all busy all busy doing their
own things spend time with their family
but
but just to know they're doing well i'll
facetime a few guys pretty often
when can you explain how nfl players get
paid
do you get paid in the off season
so it is it's breaking broken up into
signing bonuses and roster bonuses and
then obviously your game checks
uh you're gonna get every week you know
you
talking to my financial advisor you get
a better answer yeah
i try to not i try to not pay attention
[Music]
but uh yeah it's it's paid out every
every i think two weeks
whatever the game check is and it's and
you pay taxes on whatever state you
played in so
but hope it gets better every time you
play an away game
obviously when you're playing in
california but
have you ever gone to the atm and just
like just
punched in the balance inquiry just to
look at it and go wow
for the fun of it not no not really
um i mean i i'm pretty
relaxed spender i my my like i mentioned
my financial advisor really likes me
yeah
the most i'm spending on is usually food
so
well sometimes ringing up the postmates
and i have a chef
so i pretty much my biggest spending is
is on on food what does uh have you been
to the new stadium yet
uh not since it's been finished but uh
i was there i was there at the end of
the season last year and it was it was
pretty incredible
what will you miss about the old stadium
that you played in last year
oh not much really i was gonna say
no i have one thing the grass i like
playing on grass so
preferably rather than turf but you know
you're only going to be in there eight
times a game so
or eight times a year so what was your
reaction when philip rivers went to the
colts
sad i mean gonna miss him he's such a
presence in our locker room and such a
great leader
and uh obviously great talent but i
think he he looks he didn't look too bad
when in that
jersey reveal the other day when i saw
him with the colt's helmet and cultures
he looked kind of natural
yeah he looked okay do you know all of
his kids names
[Laughter]
no no i'm not going to i quizzed him on
at one time
i think it took him a little longer than
i thought it was going to there right
right he's like oh did i forget one um
when you were mic'd up that uh game
against the patriots
what did you say to brady like he has to
frustrate you because he gets rid of the
ball so quickly
you guys had a little bit of a
conversation yeah it's just tough when
you're beating guys
and then you're getting back there and
two seconds and the ball's already gone
and he's already walking up the field so
i was just like god
stop getting rid of the ball so fast and
he just slapped me on the button was
like
stop getting here so fast and i won't
have to do you ever get him
uh that game i don't believe so but the
game prior i did so do you keep a list
of who you've gotten
no no not really but uh i think a little
checklist in my head maybe
can you ask for a jersey from a
quarterback after a game
well not this year no we're not allowed
to do the jersey trades this year so
but uh yeah you could you could ask
anybody man how
do you have them i i
i i am not the one usually asking to
trade this jersey um i have a few
ohio state teammates and a few alignment
and uh
i have chris long we traded jerseys with
i
traded jerseys with so a few guys but at
the end of the game the last thing i
want to do is try to squeeze out of that
tight tight jersey
and i need about three people to help me
with so that's the main reason why i
don't ask
i wonder why don't they just cut you out
of that jersey
have you ever used scissors huh well you
got you've been the jerseys ruined and
you gotta get new jersey and i don't
know
they'll should probably charge me six
hundred dollars
hey it's good to talk to you
congratulations and um
if you were going to tell the nfl about
chase young what would you tell opposing
quarterbacks what to expect
oh man i think uh you've already seen
what the last couple
ohio state dns can do so so beware
what's your brother do better than you
i think uh he's he he kind of uses power
a little bit better i'm gonna
focus on trying to try and incorporate
that incorporate that a little more into
my game this year i'm always just trying
to
run around guys and use finesse um but i
think i need to use my power a little
bit more but last year he was just
bullying guys with this
just powering and slipping right off of
them when they're just breaking down so
i think last year definitely he used his
power really well
but you go back to that super bowl loss
what role did you play after uh he lost
that game or
the niners lost that game um
just just trying to support him and i
rode the team bus with him did you lose
me
no we got you okay yeah we got a battery
just oh there yep oh i'm losing it
you got enough money to buy a good
battery
come on come on shall we see i told you
i'm
simple but uh so you're on the niners
team bus
yeah i was just i just wanted to spend
time with him and uh
talk to him about it because i mean i
wanted him to know how well he did
and how i mean he couldn't have done
more to help that team win that game
uh and they have a great team and they
could be back next year but
it took him a while and i mean to this
day anytime there's a highlight on tv or
anything i'm like get that
get that out shut it off so
but uh it was just a big group hug our
whole family after the game
a lot of tears but uh it was it was just
so close
we i mean i think we were so close but
joe you go back to that
third down pass from mahomes to tyreek
hill
and your brother gets there a split
second that changed the game if he's if
he hits mahomes
they don't complete that sorry to bring
that off but
no no i mean he was it's true
and uh i mean it's tough but i mean
looking back at that game he really
had an unbelievable game and i don't
think he could have done much more i
think
at the end of the game the lines can get
a little lazy like ours does
and uh with a guy like mahomes you let
him out of the pocket one time and he's
gonna punish you bad
so and i mean that happened
hey go buy yourself something all right
something nice
any suggestions are you a watch guy
uh i bought a watch at once i got
drafted and i
hardly worn it
well here's the thing though joey the
best two days
are the day you buy it and the day you
sell it yeah
i i've been suggested to
get a uh membership with a boat club so
i could just
rent them that's what you should do yes
do that or maybe just get like a kayak
or something to start out with yeah
you know one step at a time
get a little i'll get a little dingy
yeah
uh hey congratulations and thanks for
joining us great to talk to you again
thanks for having me okay that's joey
bosa he's now the highest-paid defensive
player
in the nfl a uh five-year extension
worth 135